[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de la
grande interview la transition
écologique voilà un thème dont vous avez
forcément entendu parler ces dernières
années un thème que l'on retrouve
souvent dans la bouche des hommes et
femmes politiques mais aussi et dans
celle du gouvernement et pour tenter
d'engager cette transition vous envoyer
de plus en plus sur terre mais aussi
bientôt au maire je parle est des zéros
lienne en plein essor un peu partout
dans le pays
elles sont de plus en plus contesté
voilà notre thème d'aujourd'hui et pour
en parler nous sommes avec julien aubert
députés les républicains du vaucluse
mais aussi
et attention c'est long président de la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire sur
l'impact économique industriel et
environnemental des énergies
renouvelables sur la transparence des
financements et l'acceptabilité sociale
des politiques de transition énergétique
bonjour julien aubert merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui j'espère que j'ai rien
oublié north bravo bravo à quoi sert
tout simplement cette commission
d'enquêté parlementaire à cette
commission d enquête parlementaire elle
a été créée elle a terminé ses travaux
en décembre dernier à la suite de la
crise des gilet jaune
on sait que la crise des gilet jaune a
débuté sur le prix je dirais de
l'essence sur un sujet de fans mois et
puis on s'est aperçu que finalement on
invoquer beaucoup l'écologie pour
justifier ces hausses de taxes et que
les citoyens ne comprenait pas forcément
où allait l'argent donc la question de
cette commission denquête s'était
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on prélève au
nom de
de la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique est-ce que tout cet argent va
effectivement la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
et est ce que on peut estimer que c'est
efficace ou et fiction le sujet des
éoliennes étant l'un des grands sujets
évidemment de cette commission
et qu'est ce qu'il en ressort alors à
six mois après la fin de cette
commission parlementaire
le grand enseignement de cette
commission d' enquête c'est que nous
dépensons des quasiment une dizaine de
milliards d'euros par an
pour des politiques qui n'ont aucun
impact sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
ce qui pose un petit problème est que au
coeur de cette politique vous avez
notamment le financement des éoliennes
mais aussi dans une moindre mesure du
solaire alors le problème des éoliennes
étant un problème un petit peu plus
compliqué c'est à dire que non seulement
c'est une politique qui est qui coûte
cher qui est inefficace au plan
climatique mais qui en plus est au coeur
d'une forme de révolte
je dirais dans les territoires ruraux de
la part des citoyens qui ne sont pas
très heureux de voir s'implanter d'emma
très finalement assez haut qu'il
considère que ça défigure le paysage
alors la commission denquête n'est pas
parvenue elle est parvenue à un accord
bi partisan sur la plupart de ces
préconisations néanmoins l'éolien a été
un sujet de discorde entre la majorité
et l'opposition puisque tout en
reconnaissant les problèmes que posent
les aux liens la majorité n'était pas
allé jusqu'à soutenir les propositions
que faisait notamment la droite manière
d'éloignement neymar ou de précaution
sanitaire mais néanmoins il ne vous aura
pas échappé qu'à la suite de ce rapport
le président de la république avait
annoncé qu' il fallait sans doute revoir
la politique de l'éolien peut-être que
la proche la proximité des élections
municipales a aussi joué un rôle
en tout cas après les municipales eh
bien on a adopté la programmation
pluriannuelle l'énergie où pour le coup
aucun changement notable n'a été
enregistré en matière de stratégie
éoliennes vous avez commencé à répondre
à la prochaine question tout à l'heure
8000 éoliennes aujourd'hui en france
près de 20000 d'ici 2028
on imagine que c'est trop en tout cas
pour vous c'est pas une question de
savoir si c'est ou c'était trop d'abord
il faut bien prendre conscience que
derrière le mode éolien on distingue
trois technologies vous avez d'abord de
l'éolien terrestre
vous avez de l'éolien en mer et dans
l'éolien en mer vous avez l'éolien posé
qui est plutôt près des côtes et
l'éolien flottant qui lui est assez
éloignée des côtes et qui avait un
aujourd'hui de technologies plus
balbutiante que les autres la plus
mature et en l'éolien terrestre
évidemment la résistance qui peut
s'exercer de la part notamment de la
population a beaucoup plu très à
l'éolien terrestre est dans une légère
moindre mesure sur l'éolien poser en mer
après vous me posez la question du
nombre de balles a évidemment plus vous
multipliez les parcs éoliens plus vous
multipliez les oppositions parce que
vous avez des sujets de paysages mais
des sujets aussi patrimoniaux puis les
sujets de nuisance qui sont attribués à
cette type d'énergie
notamment des gens qui se plaignent bien
de problèmes de sons de bruit ou tout
simplement d'ultrasons et au cours des
auditions qui ont été faites nous avons
auditionné par exemple un éleveur de
vaches qui a vu le taux de mortalité de
son troupeau
ce à croître démesurément dont l'épousé
a été victime d'un accident de santé
c'est assez grave et pour lequel il y
avait des preuves assez concordantes
comme quoi je dirais le vibrations de
ces éoliennes s'était transmise par des
failles d'eau se trouvait dans le
terrain et qui avait conduit je dirais à
polluer en matière enfin je dirais la
santé de du troupeau et de ce
propriétaire
je me perds la course viendra bien
entendu tout à l'heure sur l'impact
sanitaire des éoliennes en france
j'aimerais qu'on revient sur ce que vous
avez dit un petit peu plus tôt en
parlant des territoires justement avec
un exemple assez concret puisque en
région nouvelle aquitaine son président
gilbert favreau dénonce une anarchie
dans la politique d'installation
d'éoliennes dont ça dans sa région il
réclame une meilleure répartition sur le
territoire national comment expliquer
déjà que toutes les régions ne soient
pas logés à la même enseigne ça c'est un
drame de conception notre politique
énergétique c'est à dire qu'on a d'un
côté à parlement qui vote de grands
objectifs massif à peu à la manière des
plans quinquennaux soviétique et donc
nous allons atteindre des milliers
d'éoliennes et grand pourcentage qui
permet d'ailleurs à la france d'abord
d'arborer la ligne pierre dans les
négociations de
des accords de paris ou de des cop et
puis ensuite vous avez d'autres
collectivités locales qui ne sont liés
par rien et qui ont leur propre
stratégie et qui peuvent être plus ou
moins favorable à tel ou tel type
d'énergie donc vous avez déjà un premier
problème c'est que finalement ces
objectifs nationaux ne sont pas décliner
ya pas de d'unité qui permettrait de
décliner territorialement de
contractualiser pour essayer de mettre
en musique ses grands objectifs
nationaux et puis ensuite deuxième
problème on confie à des promoteurs
privés
le soin ensuite d'aller démarcher donc
dans le cadre de l'éolien eh bien vous
avez une politique national
d'encouragement vous avez un dispositif
de soutien financier et vous avez des
promoteurs privés qui vont ensuite des
marchés
le propriétaire d'un champ disant voilà
voilà en quoi l'état bien peut vous
aider par va nous aider à alléger la
douloureuse est ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour me louer votre champ pour
que je construise des mâts la
collectivité pendant de la commune est
souvent mise dans la boucle
une fois que le propriétaire est
lui-même déjà d'accord la région peut ne
pas être du tout mise dans la boucle
les élus n'ont pas vraiment leur mot à
dire dans l'installation ses parcs
éoliens un peu partout sur sur dans nos
régions vous avez la commune qui je
dirais accueille le parc pour lequel
elle a évidemment parce qu'il ya des
règles d'urbanisme la capacité d'agir
mais une commune ça peut être vaste
c'est à dire que le champ en question
peut être au lit aux confins de la
commune et dont les nuisances risquent
par exemple d'impact et les communes
voisines qui sont peu près peut-être
géographiquement à ses proches
donc ça pose évidemment des sujets vous
pouvez donc avoir la commune d'accueil
qui est pour et puis vous avez les
communes autour qui vont être contre
mais elles n'ont pas de possibilités de
veto et donc vous avez ciblé une
disjonction entre les perdants et les
gagnants
le perdant très concrètement ça peut
être le chef du chemin à qui on va
installer des éoliennes en face de chez
lui à qui on n'a pas demandé son avis et
pour lequel la maison va perdre
peut-être 25% de sa valeur des as avant
même que l'éolienne sera construite
parce que le la déperdition de chaleur
se fait que ce fait avant même si vous
voulez au moment où ça s'annonce
la commune va être gagnante à va
peut-être avoir une salle polyvalente
qu'elle va pouvoir financer grâce je
dirais aux aides généreuses qui sont
données pour les promoteurs et puis
ensuite vous avez l'intercommunalité
mais ce sont d'autres qui vont peut-être
profiter d'aidés
je dirais des bienfaits de la manne et
puis au milieu de tout ça vous avez
aussi des cowboys qui font parfois de la
corruption
il ya des cas nous voilà qu'en et je
dirais les propriétaires commencent les
riverains commencent à être un peu
nerveux
on propose quelque part de les analyser
en dessous de la table
j'ai eu des témoignages comme ceux ci en
direct et puis vous avez également pas
du tout simplement des promoteurs wii
qui se comportent de très mauvaises
manières
c'est à dire qu'il essaye de faire peur
d'intimider j'avais retrouvé des
articles de presse par exemple de préfet
qui se plaignaient de méthodes de voyou
un monsieur hubert j'aimerais qu'on
parle avec vous maintenant de l'aspect
économique déjà est-ce que c'est cher
d'implanter quelque part un parc éolien
est est ce que ce parc au élire et
éolien et est vite rentable c'est cher
la question c'est pour qui oui c'est
cher le soutien à l'éolien c'est entre
70 et 90 milliards d'euros
jusqu'à 2028 pour la france sur ces 70 à
90 milliards d'euros vous en avait neuf
ont déjà été payées donc ça veut dire
que le coût de l'éolien il est devant
nous deuxièmement quand les promoteurs
éoliens 10 da écoute et l'éolien ça
revient pas cher c'est par exemple 65
euros du mégawattheures en coûts de
revient
il oublie de dire qu'en fait le coût
moyen si on prend aussi les chants qui
ont été décidés il ya cinq dix ans et
qui ont été faits à des conditions
beaucoup plus avantageuse le coût moyen
en 2010 81 89 euros du mégawattheure
donc quand on compare la rente enfin je
dirais le prix présente d'électricité
nucléaire et le prix de l'éolien faucon
il faut pas regarder les derniers champs
qui sont qui sont sortis mais le coût
réel constaté
à côté de ça donc donc ça c'est un coup
je dirais à la marge
le coût global 70 à 90 milliards d'euros
avec ça si vous voulez je peux vous
reconstruire l'intégralité du parc
nucléaire français
le parc historique puisque lui dit de
quelqu'un permet de fabriquer
concrètement ici c'est que
potentiellement la facture d'électricité
des français si on continue à créer
plusieurs parcs éoliens va va forcément
monte pas alors c'est pas financer ses
plus financé par la facture
d'électricité désormais ses financés par
les taxes qu'ils reportent sur le
carburant là les fameuses taxes
d'ailleurs qui ont provoqué des cpe etc
qui ont provoqué la colère des gilets
jaunes
c'est pour ça que c'est un vrai sujet
mais il faut se rendre compte que d'un
côté vous avez 5 % aujourd'hui de
l'électricité
d'accord on va arriver à 15% en
dépensant 70 à 90 milliards d'euros de
soutien de l'autre côté vous avez lu
nucléaire qui fournit 70 75 % de
l'électricité et pour lequel le parc
historique il ya 40 ans a coûté à peu
près la même chose
sachant que la durée de vie d'une
éolienne et pas de 40 ans et ça change
le nucléaire on peut évidemment le
repousser au delà de 40 ans donc voyez
bien que j'ai il ya un premier sujet
budgétaire là dessus c'est que ça coûte
en réalité très très cher même si
effectivement la facture va en diminuant
après on pourrait aussi raffiné parce
que je dirais le taux de fonctionnement
d'une éolienne et plus bas résume à
terre qu'en mer fonctionne 20% du temps
40% cancel l'éolien poser 60%
quand ces néo lien flottant a comparé le
nucléaire qui peut fonctionner
évidemment la quasi totalité du temps
parce que évidemment le nucléaire n'est
pas lié au vent voilà donc vous avez des
problèmes gérer des de rentabilité
derrière qui sont différents vous avez
besoin évidemment de beaucoup plus de
terrains
si vous voulez produire la même quantité
d'électricité au québec dimanche vous
avez toutes ces je dirais toutes ces
contraintes qui s'imposent
et puis il peut en rajouter d'autres
parce que une éolienne quand elle
fonctionne pas il faut quand même
produit électricité dont vous êtes
obligés de faire des centrales
thermiques à côté qui polluent et puis
vous avez aussi d'autres coûts cachés
c'est à dire que pour abaisser le coût
de fonctionnement d'une éolienne
pour arriver à ces 65 euros du
mégawattheures juste et tout à l'heure
eh bien le contribuable prend sur sa
facture d'électricité cette fois ci mais
sont ce qu'on appelle le turpe
c'est à dire le réseau c'est à dire
qu'en fait on paye le contribuable paie
le raccordement au réseau de l'éolienne
donc on lui fait facturer donc on ne
voit pas si vous voulez dans sa facture
de production mais le voit c'est un peu
technique mais dans la partie concerne
le réseau donc effectivement il en paye
quand même une partie et puis je
pourrais encore rajouter d'autres
problèmes par exemple notre émission à
monsieur le député on se retrouve dans
quelques instants on fait une petite
pause à tout de suite
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview nous
sommes toujours avec julien aubert
députés les républicains du vaucluse
pour évoquer ce grand thème des
éoliennes avec vous monsieur le député
en cette première partie d'émission a
évoqué à plusieurs thèmes j'aimerais en
évoquer un nouveau elle le le thème
sanitaire puisque vous le savez vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure des
agriculteurs des personnes se plaignent
parfois des parcs éoliens
implanté à côté de chez eux c'est le cas
d'un agriculteur que les équipes d'arte
et france ont rencontré il ya quelques
mois c'était au mois de novembre dernier
il se plaint de la santé justement de
ces bêtes nous étions allés le
rencontrer je vous propose justement de
regarder un petit extrait et on en parle
après tout de suite les travaux du site
éolien ont commencé en septembre 2012 et
en octobre 2012
on a eu une chute de production
inexpliquée avec un problème sur la
qualité du lait donc le taux cellulaire
qui flambait en juillet 2013
la situation s'est aggravée puisque là
les vaches ne voulait plus rentrer du
tout dans le bâtiment donc là on a fait
la relation puisque c'est juillet 2013
c'est la mise en route du site éolien
avec une mise sous tension des câbles
ces temps que les vaches de didier
potiron se comporte bizarrement
certaines ont même développé des
maladies inexpliqué pire encore
l'éleveur a perdu en tout plus de 300
animaux voilà on va on va regarder une
génisse en passant que je vais tâcher la
petite joy sorman qui est pareil des
symptômes du jamais vu du jamais vu au
niveau des oreilles donc là on peut on
peut observer des bouchons l'école
vétérinaire
a eu les photos c'est du jamais vu voilà
ce qu on nous répond un sujet donc
réalisés du côté de puceul dans les
pays-de-la-loire cédé en novembre
dernier par estelle farges monsieur le
député est ce qu'aujourd'hui on est en
mesure d'établir un lien entre les
éoliennes et d'éventuelles répercussions
sur la santé des animaux ont la vue mais
aussi sur sur la nôtre dans cette assez
complexe parce qu'en réalité même si on
fait des études sanitaires
on est frappé j'ai été frappé de voir
lors des auditions que par rapport à des
problèmes comme celui de monsieur
cotillons et bien les agences de l'état
n'avait pas forcément creuser ou avait
mis beaucoup de temps c'est pour ça que
moi j'ai eut déposé une proposition de
loi qui viserait notamment renforcer cet
aspect là parce que rendez vous compte
que dès que vous avez un projet public
la moindre incidence sur l'écosystème de
la loutre cendrée ou du scarabée argenté
vous allez avoir une étude
par contre quand vous implanter des mâts
éoliens à côté de d'écosystèmes humains
là assez curieusement on est assez peu
renseigné bon après vous avez aussi des
sujets assez complexe qu'on découvre
l'électrosensibilité la sensibilité aux
ondes
il ya des études qui sont faites
notamment sur les terres rares qui sont
contenus dans les dents les rotors des
éoliennes notamment le néodyme où ledit
projet homme qui pourrait à cause du
frottement se retrouver en
microparticules donc et des études qui
sont faites là dessus moi j'en suis
resté au fait qu'il n'y avait pas de
vérité pour l'instant révélé ou
scientifiquement prouvée organisme est
néanmoins on va bien qu'effectivement
dans certains cas il y a des gens qui se
plaignent et pour lequel nous n'avons
pas de réponses très précises puis un
problème plus global qui est quand même
la question du bruit et pour lequel là
c'est assez bien référence elle si
demain c'est une hypothèse un bien
entendu la communauté scientifique
venait à découvrir que les éoliennes
avait un impact sur la santé
qu'est ce qu'on ferait tous et toutes
ces éoliennes à bas ce serait une vraie
catastrophe parce que probablement qu'il
faudrait notamment celles qui sont
proches des habitations
on a quand même beaucoup
les arrêtés c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
dans la même proposition de loi je
propose de les éloigner 1,5 km notamment
lorsque la taille de l'éolienne dépasse
un certain niveau mais vous auriez une
partie du parc qui serait probablement
me d'office à l'arrêt par principe de
précaution c'est pour ça si vous voulez
je ne comprends pas toujours
l'entêtement ont certains de défendre
cette industrie
j'ai rien j'avais rien à la base contre
l'éolien simplement je constate qu'une
politique et coûte très cher qui est
inefficace écologiquement parce que vous
substituer à du nucléaire qui a déjà
lui-même décarbonés qui détruisent des
activités économiques qui créent peu
d'emplois en france et pour lequel on
est mal référencé au plan sanitaire
ça fait quand même beaucoup à mettre
dans la balance vous nous le disiez tout
à l'heure on n'est pas encore capable
aujourd'hui de rassurer 1
les gens qui vivent à côté de ces parcs
éoliens qu est ce qu on leur répond
aujourd'hui quand il quand ils se
plaignent et bien malheureusement il se
heurte à une forme d'indifférence parce
que ces preuves de l'organisation c'est
que vous avez des promoteurs privés mais
l'état n'est pas là l'état est nulle
part alors des fois vous avez des
préfets qui essaye justement de prendre
les choses en mains de jouer un rôle
d'arbitré c'est très compliqué parce que
en réalité vous aider dans des relations
largement contractuels privé vous avez
même des histoires des fois de conflit
d'intérêts ou de prise illégale
d'intérêt de la part des élus des cas
notamment de scandales de corruption ces
communes les maires sont pris en étau
parce que parfois ils soient allées de
bonne ou très bonne volonté alors que
sont un interlocuteur mais ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de moyens d'action et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est un petit peu la
jungle et puis en se penchant sur le la
rentabilité de certaines sociétés ollier
dont s'est aperçu qu'ils avaient quand
même assez peu de capitaux elles ont
constitué des réserves énormes seins et
l'ont fait fait principalement de
l'argent public
et quand je me suis permis mois en
commission denquête de poser des
questions en citant certaines sociétés
l'une d'elles m'a menacé dans la presse
en disant qu'elle a une pour ceux
enregistrés et donc donc gelé convoqué
devant la commission denquête et son
discours était beaucoup plus modeste une
fois qu'elle était convoqué devant la
commission d'enquêté je lui ai rappelé
que rien ne faisait pas obstacle au
pouvoir dans quai du parlement c'est
donc après ce qu'est ce que c'est bien
d'imposer d'imposer sa de fer larbitre
un petit peu dans ces problématiques
moi si vous voulez je crois que plutôt
que de partir d'une vision idéologique
il faudrait partir d'une vision pratique
aujourd'hui on fait des plans et un
ouvrier du vent c'est pas seulement il
ya du vent il faudra dès là où il ya des
habitats humain on ne vaudrait mieux si
vous voulez que l'état définisse un
certain nombre de sites pour lequel il
n'y a aucune proximité d'habitations ça
ferait beaucoup moins de terrain en dix
ans pour ce territoire là par contre on
fait des procédures extrêmement accéléré
une fois que vous avez l'octroi de je
dirais 2 2
de la concession voilà moyennant
d'ailleurs au passage de l'imposition de
certaines règles pour ensuite la fin du
processus quand il faut déconstruire ces
éoliennes parce que pour l'instant peut
pas dire qu'il ait provisions très élevé
dans ce domaine et puis à des problèmes
ensuite de béton problèmes de pollution
des sols on ferait mieux si vous voulez
de faire ça que de dire vous pouvez
finalement allé partout et vous
retrouver avec des parcs naturels
régionaux dans lesquels on construit des
éoliennes ou des problèmes quand vous
avez pu le site et d'éleveurs qui ont de
vrais problèmes sur leurs troupeaux ou
sur leur santé en 2018
emmanuel macron promettait la fermeture
de 14 réacteurs nucléaires d'ici 2035 à
deux ans plus tard un seul a vu son
exploitation ccs que les échéances que
s'est fixé le président de la république
vous semble réaliste
non il ya un faisceau naïm c'est pas un
seul réacteur il y en a 2 mai non parce
qu'en réalité
là encore cette vidéo logis c'est à dire
que la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est la décarbonation
aujourd'hui notre atout fort c'est
d'avoir une électricité décarbonés grâce
au nucléaire
l'idée qu'on dépense de l'argent pour
supprimer la partie décarbonés de notre
économie pour la remplacer par une autre
partie décarbonée c'est ce que j'appelle
l'équation de taux taux zéro plus zéro
c'est la tête à toto c'est à dire que
vous n'avez strictement pas bougé d'un
iota en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
et ça coûte très très cher puisque vous
avez d'un côté le démantèlement
nucléaire
de l'autre côté l'impact social
économique sur les bassins d'emploi et
vous crée effectivement des emplois dans
le domaine de l'éolien mais sont pas les
même pas les mêmes endroits pas la même
valeur ajoutée et avec des problèmes que
l'on connaît et le coût du
subventionnement donc un moment donné il
faut arrêter de croire qu'on peut se
payer deux systèmes énergétiques
on devrait d'abord réfléchir à la survie
de notre système nucléaire parce qu'on
va avoir un effet falaise avec
effectivement des éoliennes qui vont
arriver des centrales qui vont arriver
en fin de vie il va falloir remplacer
avec un coût d'investissement apprendre
de savoir-faire et deuxièmement ensuite
vous essayé de diversifier à côté mais
il n'ya pas que l'éolien ou le solaire
vous avez l'hydrogène nous avez dû le
carburant vous avez la biomasse le
biogaz ya plein de domaines sur lesquels
la france était attendue et sur
lesquelles elle aurait peut-être plus de
capacité à se démarquer au plan
international en match à technologie
sur l'éolien à part le flottant on est
largement largué vous parliez à
l'instant des emplois à fessenheim 1
plus de 2000 emplois indirects et
directes ont été supprimés beaucoup de
gens avant se retrouver bien sûr au
chômage
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut forcément
prendre en compte
aujourd'hui on est capable de reclasser
ces gens vers de l'énergie renouvelable
et non pas du tout rendez vous compte
que d'un côté vous avez peut-être mille
emplois directs plusieurs milliers
d'emplois indirects
et de l'autre côté on a une industrie
présent mais au yen qui représente dix
mille emplois
donc s'ils voulaient quand vous parlez
de 14 réacteurs en fait vous parlez d'un
ratio de un à quatre premièrement après
vous avez je dirais l'impact
géographique puis ensuite pouvez pas
dire d'un côté je ferme des boucheries
de l'autre côté j'ouvre des startups du
numérique
donc demain mais boucher vont travailler
dans les start up entre un ingénieur du
nucléaire est un fabricant de pales
c'est pas du tout le même métier c'est
pas du tout la même chose
donc tout ça ne se gagne pas et
malheureusement cette politique est
complètement inconsciente au plan géré
plan plan économique est le fruit d'un
accord politique entre
monsieur hollande et les écologistes
parce qu'il visait à montrer que la
gauche était du côté de l'écologie mais
sans même s'en rendre compte que les
écologistes français sont davantage
obsédé par la fin du nucléaire que par
le réchauffement climatique c'est-à-dire
que quand on décide de fermer des
centrales
il faut le plus les gens le comprennent
on considère qu'on a davantage peur d'un
accident de fukushima que de la peur du
dérèglement climatique
et pourtant et pourtant on n'arrête pas
de seriner aux gens que le vrai problème
c'est le réchauffement climatique est
sans doute d'ailleurs que les
conséquences économiques seront bien
plus importantes
un monsieur débuter on arrive à la fin
notre émission n'a parlé bien sûr
longuement des des aliens un peu du
nucléaire aussi quelles pourraient être
les autres solutions pour pouvoir créer
de l'énergie de l'électricité à moindre
coût et puis
surtout sans impact sanitaire et
écologique
moi je crois qu'il faut je crois si vous
voulez que l'électricité ne n'oubliez
pas ces 20% de l'énergie
c'est pas la majeure partie du problème
on est toujours obsédée par
l'électricité le poème c'est l'énergie
le problème de la france c'est d'avoir
50 à 60 milliards d'euros tous les ans
qui part pour acheter du pétrole et du
gaz
ça c'est le vrai problème de la france
est donc là où nous devons travailler
c'est dans le domaine des transports et
dans le domaine du logement
c'est ça la priorité c'est là où nous
devrions concentrer notre argent ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire des véhicules qui
fonctionne autrement que par essence ou
donc avec soin du gas oil l'hydrogène
donc ça veut dire encourager ces
filières et dans le domaine du logement
dépenses et les milliards d'euros qu'on
met sur l'éolien par exemple les mettre
dans la rénovation énergétique voir
payer aux français peut-être le
changement de la rencontre de leurs
shows de leurs modes de chauffage
vous auriez un vrai impact social et un
vrai impact en matière de co2 voilà et
pour le pôle électricité et bien faire
principalement une épine dorsale
nucléaire en sanctuarisant notre fleuron
industriel puis à côté de ça évidemment
compléter avec les différents types
d'énergies qui peuvent exister mais sans
en faire un dogme
voilà c'est la fin de cette grande
interview merci avoue julien aubert
députés à l est républicain du vaucluse
est d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
merci également à vous d'avoir suivi
cette émission une grande interview que
vous pouvez déjà retrouver sur notre
site rtl feront ce point tv à très
bientôt et rester avec nous sur arte
france
[Musique]